le maroc sur le point de produire le
vaccin sinopharm sur son propre
territoire
objectif du royaume accéléré sa campagne
de vaccination et atteindre la
souveraineté vaccinale les précisions de
notre correspondant au maghreb bassem
shellys renforcer la souveraineté
sanitaire du maroc face aux dépendance
extérieure c'est l'objectif que s'est
fixé le royaume du maroc en lançant la
fabrication locale du vaccin chinois
sinopharm objectifs à court terme une
capacité de production de 5 millions de
doses par mois
une coopération signés acté entre le
royaume du maroc le groupe
pharmaceutique chinois lors d'une
cérémonie présidée par le roi mohamed 6
d'un montant global d'environ 2 421
millions d'euros selon l'agencé de
presse marocaine
objectif pour les autorités sanitaires
accélérer l la campagne vaccinale a
débuté au mois de janvier
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet il
sera à bourabi maître de conférences à
sciences po rabat c'est une immunité qui
est qui est déjà en place et qui va
conduire continuer notamment avec ce
nouveau projet qui permettra notamment
d'assurer une certaine souveraineté en
matière de production et de moins
dépendre est bien de l'importation de
vaccins et pour ça c'est une très bonne
chose que la coopération commence dans
ce sens là c'est à dire que l'on puisse
déléguer la fabrication que l'on puisse
mettre en place des coopérations entre
pays pour la fabrication puisque c'est
une crise qui concerne absolument tous
les pays avec plus de 10 millions de
marocains vacciner sur une population
totale de 36 millions d'habitants le
maroc malgré un nombre d'infections à la
hausse est l'un des pays d'afrique et du
maghreb où l'on vaccine le plus un bilan
bien plus mitigée pour son voisin
tunisien qui connaît une recrudescence
importante des cas de contamination
tunis et peine toujours à faire décoller
sa campagne vaccinale est temps
d'accélérer ses partenariats en vue
d'acquérir plus de doses les autorités
viennent d'annoncer l'arrivée sur le sol
tunisien de 500 mille doses de vaccin
sinovac en provenance de la république
populaire de chine